hey guys what's up this is andrew for
sentences.com so i'm here guys i'm back
from boca del toro and i'm here to make
a big update on amc ngme we are entering
a week where i think something big can
happen so let's get into it
alright guys so we're gonna start first
with amc so let me quickly uh remind you
what i was saying in my last video
i'm sorry i didn't do a video on monday
this is because i was traveling so it
was not easy at all um
but i'm gonna do a video every day this
week because i think that something big
is about to happen so first
let's make a recap of the situation the
situation is on amc
that we were correcting for two three
months we had here this breakout on
increasing volume
uh that is showing
that boost to back control right
whenever this happens the higher we go
with the more strengths the better it is
because usually this is only the first
wave then we have the second wave third
fourth and fifth wave this is the usual
bullish development that we see in
pretty much every asset and amc
is not an exception this is what we had
uh back in jan this is what we had back
in may so i think that the same thing is
about to happen
so
um
i was saying in the last video that the
first wave is complete it's respecting
fib projection ratios let me quickly
show you again that
for those who haven't seen it
okay so just measure one plus three and
you check if you apply to the bottom of
the force and you check if the top of
the fifth is a fib ratio it can be open
six one eight it can be one point six
one eight here it was one point six one
eight it was also the 32 3233 resistance
natural resistance level that we had
with a trend line and with the 200-day
moving average so it was kind of
making sense we reached that level and
then we start to correct so this is what
i was predicting and this is what
happened so then the correction can last
like i said between a few days and
maximum let's say two weeks okay and i'm
gonna explain as well why if nothing
happens before april 14th it won't be
looking good at all um
and i'm gonna tell you what i think it
might happen if unfortunately we don't
squeeze by april 14th but
the preferred scenario is definitely
that we start to move higher soon i was
telling you guys in my last video that
we should start to see
the bullish momentum back in the middle
of this week so tomorrow is wednesday so
either tomorrow or thursday it can of
course happen later but wednesday or
thursday was
my initial time target
um
then let me quickly go through the press
action we had today
so it was not a good day we
were down nine percent so
let me show you why to me this is still
totally fine i just measure the first
wave and i check fib ratios everything
that is above the 61.8 percent uh fib
retracement ratio is totally acceptable
as a second wave second waves like to go
between the 38.2 and the 61.8 so the
higher we stay like jimmy we're gonna
see that very soon the better it is for
the coming third wave uh in amc's
situation we
we have corrected to do 61.8
retracement today guys we reached 21 21
is also a natural
support so here i have 21.0
weight we went to 21. okay let me get
rid of that so for now the second wave
is totally i would say usual typical
sometimes we see second wave is going
slightly beyond the six 1.8 percent but
uh usually when this happens the
probability that we have a massive third
wave is just lower so for now it is all
looking good the 21 level is also the
recent high that we the recent highs
that was um that were reached once twice
here three times so we had three
reactions in the past in the past three
months
four reaction here on then six and five
reactions so it's a pivot point which
means that whenever we are above that
level we are bullish and whenever we are
below that level we are bearish right
simple rule so we are still above that
level it has been reached today so i
expect that we get uh a bullish reaction
from here so probably tomorrow or
thursday then the only reason i think we
miss we're gonna start to move higher on
top of the fact that usually second
waves last uh roughly half of the time
the first wave has last
um so the second reason is look at the
rsi guys rsi daily time frame
there are many different ways to use the
rsi
oversold
of a boat and the 50 neutron area and
usually it's not true for every stock
it's not true for every time frame but
you just check if it if it worked in the
past and usually the 50 level is
followed by traders which means that
whenever we are below that we are
bearish and when we come to the 50
levels the 50 level uh traders start to
take a
selling position in this situation this
is what happened as you can see since uh
november 22nd when we broke out below
this 20 to this 50 level and then we
just stayed below that level and each
time we were getting close to 50 or just
above we were having a selling reaction
i think that now things that have
changed like i said because of this
breakout as you can see it's the first
time that we broke out as well above
this 50 level so it's another reason to
believe that this breakout is different
from what we had before
as can be seen on the rsi
then we we arrived to the overbought
area we got rejected totally fine we
took back some energy which is needed
and look guys where we are coming right
now we are coming to this 50 area so
we're not there yet we are right now at
52.13
so maybe we're gonna drop a little bit
more
and we can even go to 48 49 it's not
very precise but in this area between 45
and 55
bulls are gonna start to attack so this
is what i'm expecting to happen
like i said tomorrow or thursday
um
something else i wanted to say yes also
what is important is to see that we
correct on lower volume as can be seen
here we don't like to see increase in
volume especially on big moves and here
today we move down by nine percent but
with a very small volume so it means
that
um even when the market is going through
some major levels there were not booze
gathered here i mean much
less bulls than what we had during the
move up okay so for now bulls are making
money bears are losing money okay so
this is important this is how i
personally interpret the volume i don't
like to see bulls losing a lot of money
because whenever you lose money you
don't go again with the same sizes in
your trade all right usually go smaller
i will personally buy some calls
tomorrow in my discord i gave a plan
that i'm going to follow which is an
average
buy of different calls different
maturities i go from april to july
and
the more you wait the more the
volatility is going to drop and
especially if amc comes back to 21 you
have a double
uh advantage of uh of buying calls uh in
this area
so
once again tomorrow i'm gonna buy calls
fran i'm gonna buy calls next week i'm
gonna buy calls whatever the price
whatever happens uh because this is my
plan i'm gonna show you guys something
very interesting on the option market
uh let me just conclude yeah uh the last
thing i wanted to tell you guys about
this price action is that
we went to 21 and i've always said that
below 21 it's not looking good but once
again sometimes second wave goes
slightly uh beyond that level
but once again if it happens the
probability that we see a massive
massive third wave is lower
also second waves like to go to the top
of the third wave preceding subwave
which is 22 that got broken today
and that's why we had this kind of
strong
move down after 22 got broken because as
you can see 22 acted very well as
support as as being the top of the third
wave so bulls were here bulls were not
strong enough but once again look at the
volume very low so most of the bulls
actually didn't get involved for now and
i think they're gonna
just arrive soon because once again we
have many um technical reasons to
believe that bulls are about to take
back control
uh
the
second wave can also go to the bottom of
the force wave so we're gonna monitor so
this the bottom of the force wave is at
19 so if 21 breaks
we are likely to go just like we did
today a strong move down around 10 20
percent maybe 219 and then a strong
buddhist reaction so once again i don't
know if you're gonna go to 21. i don't
know if you're going to go to 19 uh what
i know is that i'm gonna buy tomorrow
and if we go lower i'm gonna keep buying
because at some point we're gonna have i
think this reversal that's gonna happen
uh then i wanna show you guys something
interesting as well on the option market
stay with me because you're gonna see
i'm gonna do it quickly it's gonna be
very interesting bam so i'm retrieving
all the options from the option market
bam bam bam and what i want to show you
guys is sorry one sec bam let me mute
that okay
what i want to show you is that um
most of the options we have on amc that
is grooming we have a maximum synthetic
short that is growing as you can see
so here we have a lot of options on the
30 40 60 strike
and what is interesting so this is
creating troubles for market makers once
again because they are short those
options those call options i'm here only
having the core options
um and whenever the price action goes
higher they need to buy shares on the
upside so this is a short gamer position
that they have and that they need to
hedge by buying shares whenever we move
up so if we move strongly up they need
to buy more shares so this is creating
some bullish momentum coming from the
option market and whenever you have that
many options the bullish momentum on the
upside is very strong just like we've
seen last week and the week before uh
and here what is interesting is to see
that
most of it
18 million shares okay we have actually
even force of airplane
that has expired all right so this need
to be removed then force of empty first
person
okay and as you can see 14
uh
18 million shares
are
located on the 14th of april maturity
it's it's massive guys because look at
may it's half of that
uh
july is big as well
so i think that if something
is about to
happen uh soon it's gonna happen before
the 14th of april because after that
date we're going to lose 80 million
shares so maybe they're going to be
rolled we're going to analyze that but
when we come close to this expiries it
creates creating once again a lot a lot
of volatility in the market and this is
what we want to see
okay so and whenever we start to move
higher guys i think it's going to be
very brutal third waves are usually more
stronger more impulsive more volume more
volatility once again we still have some
room guys here
on the volume look at this
low volume okay it's not that low
226 million shares but it's slow
compared to what we've seen before and i
think that this new wave up if it
happens once again i don't know if it's
going to happen but this is what i'm
playing personally
um and if it happens i believe it's
going to be stronger than everything
we've seen before so we can expect a
massive massive volume to happen in this
third wave then we don't know if the
third wave is going to be the stronger
or the fifth wave but we're gonna have a
massive third wave uh for sure if we go
above 32 33 which is the top of the
first wave which is the major resistance
that we have right now which is this
upper band
triangle upper band in blue that you can
see here so for now we are far from that
but we can go there very quickly
okay now let's do jamie jamie is in the
same situation a little bit like amc
which makes total sense but
we are here holding much stronger which
is very good news because
those two are going to move together and
if i see jaime very strong like that
it gives me you know more
uh hope for amc third wave massive third
wave to arrive even if we go below the
61.8 percent on uh ratio fibration on
amc like i told you in at the beginning
of the video so seeing gme that is as
you can see if i measure here i have my
waves exactly the same way i'm using a
regular scale um
which is not the case on amc because i
have better reactions with the regular
scale on jme
and when i use the scale i measure the
first wave so one two three four five i
measure that i check my fib ratios and i
can see that the 153 level where we are
right now is the 28.2
fib ratio so
uh this is much higher than what we have
on amc which is once again at the 61.8
percent
field retracement of the first uh move
up
uh so this is telling me once again that
amc is starting at a discount compared
to gme so i have of course some jamishas
but for now i'm gonna buy amc because uh
the discount between those two i'm
completing this
uh almost every day guys so i can show
you bam bam bam right now it is
17
percent no that's not correct
up
there one sec
okay sorry i need to do it manually so
amc yeah mc is at 21 and jamie is at 153
ah okay i know this was correct 17 sorry
everything is good so uh amc is selling
at a discount of 17 compared to gme uh
we don't know if the discount will last
uh for long
but i personally
uh believe that
it won't so this is the reason why i
personally prefer to base buy some mx
amc shares for now
now we also can see that on gme
as you can see here we only so first we
came on the 38.2 uh fib ratio which is
once again a support level uh
i want to show something on the mc sorry
guys very quickly but just for those who
you know don't really use fibs and you
know you're wondering if those
fibrations are really giving reactions
look at that
i measure you can do it yourself you
measure the first wave okay from bottom
to top
okay and look at the vibrations so the
first 26
gave us one reaction here
one two three four reactions here then
the 50 ratio gave us one direction here
one two three four five and like ten
reactions here so i mean you can see
that sellers and buyers are organized
around those ratios and once again uh
the 21 uh
level which is the 61.8 ratio gave us
today five reactions on the hourly time
frame so i mean you can't
you can say that
uh fibs are not easy to make money which
is true because you have many ratios and
you don't really know exactly if which
one is going to hold you know that it's
not that easy to use but you can't deny
the fact that buyers and sellers are
just located just below and just above
those ratios so on gme the same thing
can be said we are right now only at the
38.2 percent fee
ratio of the first move up
so this is a support level which doesn't
mean for sure that it's going to hold
but the probability that we see a bounce
from here is just higher than the
parameter we see a bounce from any other
level uh also we can see that we are
just here
um just having
many reactions on this blue trend line
which is the triangle upper band using
the regular scale once again uh on jme
and you can see that uh it's it's
supporting the price action very well
guys since we just broke out brew to
this fruit once again the breakout is
here
bam
okay
so after this breakout
buyers are organized around vibrations
of the first move up okay as usual but
they're also organized around this
major resistance resistance line that
has been broken and as long as we are
above that we are very very bullish
looking very good we can even go below
we could go here uh 230 i would still be
bullish
but the fact that we hold that high is
very good news for what is about to come
um
what else can i tell you guys here yeah
the rsi is still at 57 so better than uh
amc
so
i think from what i'm seeing that we
have many different reasons on amc and
gme to believe that
very soon tomorrow thursday maybe later
we don't know but once again i
personally
buy i started to buy even before in the
move down and i'm going to keep buying
and i have many orders
until the end of this week and next week
as well until april 14th once again
because we can see that this expiries
are extremely
uh big on gme and amc let me show jme
guys i showed you that already but maybe
some of you didn't see
look at that guys it's the first time
i've seen that and this is one of the
reason i personally believe very
strongly that
uh the squeeze is about to come
because look at that guys one sec
give it some time
come on
okay
okay so the maximum synthetic shock guys
is at 30 so we lost
10 percent of it compared to last uh
friday because we have april first
expiry
uh but it is still absolutely massive
thirty percent is a lot aims he was only
18
um
i'm checking that for many stocks i
don't see often something bigger than 15
20 on the maximum synthetic short the
currency synthetic shock is eight
percent the regular short interest is 19
so we have a total of 27 which is around
uh three two point seven for the gtc so
once again the dds 2.7 is not uh
an area where shorts would start to
cover they would start to cover much
higher so for now
we are gonna move higher i believe
because we're gonna have buyers buying
massively
and
then we're gonna have shorts buying even
higher and this is uh what is gonna
create i believe the short squeeze that
should come once again between you know
maybe start tomorrow or thursday and we
have i would say around two weeks be
before april 14th for this third wave to
really start now let's quickly discuss
what could happen
if nothing happens uh by the by april
14th it's possible okay we've seen many
bull traps before
uh i'm also having a quite bearish view
guys on the global market okay i'm
updating
you guys in discord and
i'm regularly doing videos
on triple q and spy and i told you guys
i personally took a short position at
370 on spy on triple q let's do triple q
those two are going to move together my
view on triple two is that i can give
you quickly this view them
my view is that we're gonna drop
and maybe oscillate a little bit here
and then the direction will be taken
either up above 370 maybe in may june
and or down but for now i think we are
uh
rather bearish
so i'm wondering if we're gonna see this
negative beta taking place which means
the market is dropping and amcgme moving
strongly higher which happened
five times in the past uh whenever we
had massive moves up so i think that we
might be in this situation let's see
um i don't know but
i'm just trying to you know have a
global view
about what i see on the global market
and what i see on meme stocks also we've
seen that utter um there was mullen
before
uh there was
there were a few stocks we saw twitter
moving strongly i was
twitter is not a meme stocks uh yeah tkt
tk80 so i can show you that quickly guys
i'm not going to do a full tier here but
we can see those stocks are starting to
move strongly higher and
so here atter took
60 on monday
then minus 11 percent
yesterday no sorry okay basically it
moved by in a matter of three days this
was friday oh yeah sorry this was friday
so in a matter of three days it moved up
by sixty percent so this is ticket and
atter as well
very strong moves up on monday yesterday
and today up six percent whenever the
rest of the market was dropping so
uh
what is this telling us i remember guys
and maybe you do too whenever we saw i
don't know back in the time it was uh
d-wack and p-h-u-n moving strongly
higher those two were squeezing uh you
know small meme stocks squeeze
uh during this time amcg consolidate
correct a little bit we see outflows
from
the two big legendary squeeze stocks
which are amc and jamie going into those
small squeeze opportunities those small
squeeze opportunities they never hold
high they always get destroyed
afterwards so here i don't know if we're
going to go higher it looks bullish to
me
but what i think is that um
you know the reddit crowd and you know
all the investors that get in those
place they are making money and this
money eventually is gonna get back to
amc and gme like it has always been the
case so um
once again i can see those squeezing
maybe they're gonna go higher maybe
tomorrow we're gonna have um a rotation
of the money between those small squeeze
plays and the real big uh the real
squeeze plays which are once again amc
and jamie so this is one more reason
that is making me quite confident in the
fact that amc and jamie are gonna come
back once again i repeat because i can
see investors that love amc and jamie
making money on other stocks we know
this are the same guys so this money is
going to come back once again soon in
mcme and
like i said we have low volume look at
gme volume it's back to what it was
before we started to move strongly
higher so
we saw we see this this small volumes on
the set in the second wave through back
so this is very easy for for bulls to
you know make the bullish momentum
coming back again uh once again look at
the volume that had that happened during
this first wave we can do the same if
the same players arrive and start to buy
the same thing is going to happen so i
think that we are coming to this very
soon so that's it for today i hope you
guys enjoyed this video and if you did
please don't forget to click on the sub
like and bell button so you're gonna be
the first to know when i upload anything
new and stay close to show see you guys